hey guys welcome to odd man out kpop
super fans but before we get into the
video
i just want to tell you that we here at
jubilee are trying to get to know
you the community so we can brainstorm
ideas and come up with some cool stuff
that you actually care about for 2021 so
make sure you click
on the link below and fill out the
anonymous survey
now let's get into the episode kpop
k-pop 90 million k-pop fans worldwide
has become a worldwide cultural
phenomenon
we truly have the best fans in the world
we brought together seven k-pop super
fans i'm a k-pop super fan i'm a k-pop
super fan
i'm a k-pop super fan i'm a k-pop super
fan i'm a k-pop super fan i'm a k-pop
super fan
i'm a k-pop super fan
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll win a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the cash
prize
this is odd men out
the mole is either a fan of like one
group but not kpop as a whole
or they live with a k-pop super fan i'm
just going to try and be myself using
that k-pop winger you know
ask the most basic questions like what
group are you into
if someone were to say bts or black pink
i'm going to be sus all right you have
all these people who just found out
about bts i have been there since the
beginning bro i'm actually so nervous
like if you can see my hands
i'm literally sweating right now i know
my stuff but at the same time i feel
like i'm gonna blank because i don't
know
anything i don't know dates i don't know
the name of your dog
i'm i'm not gonna make it i
what's everyone's all right so my
favorite group is
the first group though my favorite group
is
80s i really like black pieces
same yeah i love black pink their new
album oh my god
yes so good not a bad track on the new
album
miles card though hidden card here my
current favorite group is bts
my favorite group absolutely is 21. yes
yes yes back amazing what got everyone
into k-pop
oh that's a good big bag orange caramel
orange caramel
[Music]
i love orange caramel nana was like my
first celebrity crush my daughter's in a
dance
cruise so that's how i that's how i got
into k-pop oh that's so cool that your
daughter and you are
oh that's amazing oh i got in it kind of
a sad way i used to not have a lot of
friends so on the train home from high
school i listened to shiny
i got into kpop with my best friend she
had actually moved
from south korea and was like look at
what we got and i was like okay yeah but
i really fell into it with shiny with
replay i was obsessed
you already know i was supposed to see
bts coming in chicago from apple seoul
oh my god are you from chicago
i'm from minnesota but i was gonna drive
chicago for the two days i was supposed
to see
monsta x but the shutdown was a week
before it started it was the worst
i was so pissed i yeah the
round was just very hectic everybody had
such good answers and i thought it was
going to be obvious i don't know
i feel like some of these these guys are
like o.g k-pop fans and i'm not
because i only got into kpop a few years
ago
eeny meeny miny i'm just gonna vote i'm
just gonna vote
for it send us i'm really sorry honey i
feel like you didn't really have enough
to say
i'm going to vote for troy i don't know
i just seemed like he was a little bit
nervous
frankie she said her daughter is a k-pop
fan everything she's
learned could be from her daughter i
feel like that could just be her
daughter's room
her thing seems so picture perfect and
set up with like the frames and i feel
like a fake fan would like do
that much i think i'm just gonna have to
pick andrew because
for no reason other than i don't know
anyone to pick and my ex-husband's name
was andrew
the votes are in for round one and the
person eliminated this round
is frankie
i can't believe this i'm actually a bit
i'm
upset about being eliminated because
because i was really enjoying this
i think i'm eliminated because i'm an
older fan how is she
eliminated i'm in a blank wall and they
eliminated her and all her k-pop merch
there's no hope
[Music]
you will have 10 minutes to search and
gather your most
prized kpop related merchandise okay
okay getting my stuff here oh my god so
much rummaging
there goes the boa shiny album monsta x
2pm xo i
made t-shirts for super m because i
hated the ones that sme capital records
made it's literally only bts merch
though i'm gonna get flame
people have constantly pointed out like
do you own socks that aren't kpop
it looks like a why
if you understand my reference your
actual true kpop super fan this is my
door
my desk drawer i already had a bunch of
my stuff
up and ready for us i got this album and
this is my bias
this is my kpop box it's really bad
normally this is locked
so here is my sign monsta xcd my kcon
these billboards here's the love of my
life tiffany
young stephanie young juan i went to the
vancouver show
i went to the party show
here's the thing i support k-pop through
itunes nowadays so i'm going to print
out
what i have on my itunes not
all of us can afford every single app
okay hey guys so this is my boa 20th
anniversary large soju glass i love
bowling
all my life this is my super m t-shirt
that i had made
21 all my life crush you know it already
we love 21. we love fx i know she's an
original fan
2 pm grown and then lastly my nct 127
apple music event t-shirt i don't know
how i got in
but god saw me he said you're going and
so i went and i saw them and i got this
t-shirt at the end
this is actually a convention it's
called k-pop north and i was actually a
volunteer for it so i got to meet
a bunch of different people i also
volunteered at kcon new york it was
so much fun every single iu album every
single black people
oh this man has taken hold on i'm never
going to doubt him in my life
on my wallet i literally have my cheesy
photocard
and my dad actually thought this was my
girlfriend and i had to tell him it
wasn't
so disappointed by that my first item is
right on the wind by card i stand card
i love cards i don't have a lot of
merchandise because i am a broke college
student
i'm not even in college and i'm broke i
am going to show you guys
i support through itunes like
luna didn't go number one for nothing so
but there's the black pink ceo dream
catcher that is dedication
thank you you love in orbit jesse by the
way oh my god
yes yes okay so i have
two signed albums from jisoo and jenny
i'm so
jealous i've never seen signed blackpink
albums i have no idea how she got that
i have this vt21 it's chimi i love
chiming's
and then i have so many albums i'm
conflicted with sundays
she has items but they're very
mainstream black pink bts
okay i'll try and go fast um i have
every like limited
edition bts members on billboard for the
cover
i have every single one i went to 16
different barnes and nobles to get it um
absolute
legend troy we stan barnes noble's
k-pop heaven hold on
new york am i a fan wait a minute three
signed monsta x albums
um i've been wearing it since the
beginning it's one of my most precious
things it has bts's debut day i have
shooky
and tiny shooky fix socks and bts socks
gee who is my bias in bts
i bet you can't tell own a bunch of bts
albums yeah it's all bts stuff
so i'm thinking she's like just a bts
fan and not a kpop super fan
seeing people's merchandise definitely
helped me seeing people's merchandise
not help at all i'm gonna vote for dara
i think it's just like the fact that her
only albums are just
from a long time ago i feel like she
might not be a current fan of k-pop
i'm going to vote for andrew because i
think the most
obvious one maybe sometimes could be the
mole i guess i'm just going to vote for
ava this time just because all of her
stuff was bts but she did have the big
socks
sanders she has a lot of mainstream
merchandise
i feel like she had two things that were
great but that was
it i'll just vote for dara wait no i'm
not going to vote for her i like her too
much
i guess i'd vote for hami again
i feel bad though we have counted all
the votes
and the person eliminated this round is
sundas really cinders
this sucks
this was very difficult and i'm so sorry
guys but the only music video i could
think of right now is after school bang
i literally watch this every day after
school bangs are bob
first of all after school very talented
group they learn things for their music
videos they did the tap dancing they did
the drums they did the pole dancing they
had that iconic hip part where they
turned they hit the hips
swing swing swing
the first one that came to mind of
course is by cars gunshot their newest
release
it's actually a really deep music video
and it means a lot because this is the
last video
of them for before jason endless in the
military they each write about how
online words and bullying hurt idols and
how toxic
the fan base can actually be hit me like
a gun
boom boom
you know i'm gonna talk about luna um
mine
is eb's new so how luna works is they
all debuted as singular members they
reverse
engineered how groups are made the whole
song is about accepting yourself
and being true to yourself and there's
also a lot of bisexual coding
and it was this moment where i realized
luna was so important
and how how important kpop is in general
because k-pop has pushed so many
boundaries and moved so many people
forward troy is really fascinating
i agree i don't think k-pop's a leader
in sexuality though i disagree with that
because the company is so strict it is a
rebellious act for a k-pop fighter to go
on stage and say
i support lgbtq and they hold up rainbow
flags so i think my favorite changes
literally every year of course right now
it's not shy by itsy it doesn't have the
deepest story but i think it's a really
fun video i'm a film major so i think
people don't really appreciate how hard
it is to shoot some of these videos they
have these insane cut shots i learned
the whole dance like not shy i mean
it's bad it's something like i can watch
when i'm feeling down when i'm feeling
happy it like really cheers me up
yes okay she she knows she's a fan i'm
not satisfied
after school subunit orange caramel i'm
specifically talking about the catalana
music video what i love about is that
they kind of push the boundaries
they literally dress as sushi they're
literally swimming in soy sauce
they incorporate comedy into their music
videos which is not something
a lot of members do
i don't know truly truly i find it hard
to believe that any of these people are
the moles i think i'm gonna go with
andrew again
everyone had like a unique group and
then
he said what dara had also said i'm
definitely most suspicious
of ava now you know she only talked
about bts and then she just mentioned
itsy she's only talking about the main
level groups sorry andrew much love
i think you're the mole actually i think
i'm gonna do dara
i'm sorry dara i love you dar i
literally love you
i just feel like dara just isn't into
kpop as much as she used to be
i'm not sure i think i'm gonna vote for
troy
just to mix it up and the person
eliminated this round
is andrew oh i knew it
oh i have no way i have no idea
andrew was going wow
bye-bye and the question is
do you guys want to continue the game if
everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all
you can end the game now but if majority
has doubt
the game will continue i don't know
i don't know i don't suspect these
people but i feel like four is like a
high number you know
guys i'm exhausted what should we do
guys what do you guys think at home
i'm so suspicious of zara
there's one more question i just kind of
want to get out there so i feel like
being a kpop super fan
like is also recognizing that there are
many things wrong
in the kpop industry for example the the
suicide i was a huge fan of shinee
and i was a really big fan of aoa so
hearing about the bullying
between jimin and nina was really hard
to hear
and i was wondering if there's any sides
you guys have seen that like you are
willing to work to change within the
k-pop industry
i think that sassings like are super
toxic to be so obsessive and not let
them have their
freedom the the like really crazy
like stalkering it's just crazy to me
and also i'm not an anti-fan i don't
like that i'm not gonna go on
bts page or someone's patient just click
dislike
one thing in particular um i'm really
big on like cultural appropriation
saying certain words and things like i
really
fight about these things um just because
i feel like
you know what you're doing you just
don't care and that to me says that you
don't want me to be your fan
one of the members from secret code i
believe she posted black lives matter on
her instagram and her company like took
it down did you guys hear about that
whoa
that's messed up i do have a really good
question for you guys who do you think
is responsible for the blow up of kpop
like i know some people say bts i know
some people say boa girl's generation
big bang big bang okay i will say boa
yeah i was gonna be bella i remember her
dropping did it for love
and i was like now what and what like i
just was
blown away i feel like bts got to where
they are because these other groups kind
of opened the way
i'm not suspicious of anyone i'm
probably going to vote for jaime
jaime knew a lot he really understands
k-pop
dar is good like there's no doubt in my
mind that dara is not a super fan i've
known since freaking round two
so i'm going to have to vote for ava
this round i feel so bad we shouldn't
have done another round
i'm so sorry dary like i feel so bad
voting for you
guys we made a mistake we're all k-pop
stance this is
no i don't know why we continued on
forgive us
i will vote for um
my heart is pounding you guys i'm so
nervous
and the person eliminated this round is
ava
[Music]
yeah we have three people left
are we going to round five or not no
we definitely caught them all i'm very
confident in this final three we we
caught them all
darling i feel you troy i know you
so if the color that shows up behind me
is green you all win
if it's red the mole is still in the
game and you lost
i'm looking at jaime right now and you
look mad suspicious right now
in three two one
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god it's not dara it has to be
behind me
i knew it was zara it was jaime
oh
i know exactly who the mole is i know
it's highmate
the game is over and the k-pop super
fans have lost
that means the mole has won and will be
receiving a cash prize
we're also going to be gifting them all
the akintu experience
where they will get to pick their
favorite basics from our new interactive
apparel brand
will the mole please raise your hand in
three
two one
hi guys
wow
i suspected everyone except you like
honestly
i'm a music publicist i've been in the
industry for quite a few years now
i honestly only know the basics i
couldn't name a single member
of bts but i definitely respect you guys
you know working as a publicist
kpop would not be what it is today
without its fans wait did you go to kcon
as like a publicist
no i didn't those were my friends for
the slits that i got
we literally voted out four super fans
and kept the mole in well i guess a true
k-pop super famous i don't see someone
that's just willing to have some fun
someone who loves the music who doesn't
trash other groups
we are all races all genders all ages
and it's really much bigger than most
people think
i think for so long we've lived in a
world where
we've treated music and mainstream music
especially in western markets as only an
english
thing kpop has literally changed my life
it's given me the excitement back to
actually go out and do things you know i
just used to be so
insecure about my ethnicity and who i am
as a korean
uh seeing how popular k-pop has gotten
over the 10 years and seeing how many
people are interested in k-pop that's
made me proud to be south korean
so for that i'm going to always be
grateful towards kpop
i hope you enjoyed that episode i had a
blast directing it and meeting so many
passionate k-pop fans
if you're a k-pop fan make sure you
comment below with who's your favorite
k-pop artist or
k-pop group and if you're not a kpop fan
you can leave some suggestions for
future odd man out episodes
don't forget click on the link below and
fill out the anonymous survey
this will help us out to get to know you
the community
so we can brainstorm cool ideas and cool
stuff that you actually
care about for 2021 thanks for watching
hit that like button make sure you share
this video with family and friends
and until next time